All right, folks, welcome back.
So Lord willing, after the holiday weekend, I'll be back next Tuesday.
So here we have the E-mini S&P daily chart, and you can see we have a nice delivery to
the upside.
Initial draw was inside this area in here, up into the bearish order block.
Now notice that we traded up into this up close candle with today's range, didn't quite
take out this high.
I think that's the next area to look for, but in here, when we're looking at a candle
that we're using for the order block, the low, the open, and the middle of the range,
those are the three sensitive areas that you're watching for.
If the market trades up into the middle point of that candle, this is what I call the mean
threshold.
Mean threshold was taken today, and that to me bodes well for a continuation to take out
this short-term high.
So if you take your Fib and you run it across this candle to 50% level, all right, here's
the 15-minute time frame, here's yesterday's trading, turned up into that small little
area down here into that low.
I mentioned that was going to be a likely candidate for upside relative equal highs
as well.
We traded back down into a fair value gap, optimal trade entry, rallies up, takes out
buy-side liquidity above the short-term high back here, which I don't unfortunately have
in my chart, but you can see that on your own 15-minute time frame.
And then we consolidated ahead of today, and then during the crossover into New York midnight,
a small little Judas swing where it drops down, creates the low of the day, rallies,
leaves relative equal highs in here, and this high intact.
It drops down, rallies once more, small little retracement, and then it does a shallow run
above 4,000 on this past year.
In this small little area on the lower time frame, I used this little retracement to highlight
a run to 4,000, so I gave you guys 4,000 as my objective.
It hit it, and then we pressed deeper into the order block on the daily chart, which
creates this whole run here.
Now I'm going to go into the details about that here, but for now just know that we were
trading up to this level, failed to go to that same level, consolidated right below
that daily bearish order block.
That's the low of the candle that creates that daily bearish order block, and then the
opening when that counts a little bit higher, I think it's 4,002, but don't pull me to
it, look at your own chart.
So we had a small little pass above 4,000, retraces back down in, we'll look at the lower
time frames in all of this price action now.
These are the 5 minute candle, this run here to here.
This price leg is part of this price leg.
Notice how this candle's high to this candle's low, that range, that range right there has
one single pass, whereas this one has one, two.
Notice that, low, high, small retracement, and then a second level running.
Because it had two stages to this delivery, I want to use this most recent one, and this
is my dealing range, short term low, the short term high.
I run a fib on that, and I showed this in a short little vignette I posted on my Twitter.
Twitter handle is I am the ICT.
So it's at symbol, capital I, underscore, A-M, underscore, T-H-E, underscore, I-C-T.
So a lot of people over there pretending to be me, and maybe they're just, I don't know
if it's fanfare or what it is, but some of them have been asking for money, I'm not asking
you for money, and I'm never going to ask you to DM me, I'm never going to DM you.
So if it ain't being posted publicly on Twitter, it isn't me.
So this dealing range here, I measured the low to the high, 50% is equilibrium, I'm going
to see it drop down into discount.
This small little area down here, fair value gap, we want to look at that on the lower
time frame.
So from this run here to here, I know some of you are going to ask, and some of them
are bringing it up today on Twitter.
What about the times you said for the model?
Teaching you something that is outside of the model as the reasons why you're not going
to anticipate or see that typical setup, that's the whole point of why I did it today, plus
I have a lot of personal things I take care of and administrative work in my private group.
So with that said, the market rallies in here, drops down in to the fair value gap there,
once more above the 4,000 level, and then going into, here's the 830 by the way, this
is the 830 candle, and you can watch when it trades right into that fair value gap.
It rallies again, drops back down in, and then at 930, this candle here explodes to
the upside, takes off, and starts digging deeper into that.
So it traded up into almost the 4,074 level looks like almost, so we'll be looking for
a continuation of the upside 4,095, 4,100 is next consideration.
I want to take you into the price action down in here and give you more details as to why
I was willing to take something a little bit earlier today.
Okay, if you plot the NASDAQ June contract for 2022, and on the compare chart on TradingView,
if you go up into your TradingView platform, you'll see like a little plus symbol up here,
if you click on that, it'll give you an opportunity to add another instrument, and you add this
symbol here, NQM2022, and it'll plot a line chart, but it's usually going to be plotted
on the close, it's like a default.
You want to change that in the settings by just right-clicking over here, or highlight
over top of it, and it'll give you like a little gear or something, click on that and
change settings to, and just change it to plotting on the low, because you're comparing
lows.
As you can see, the NASDAQ went lower here, whereas the EME S&P failed to go lower.
That's an SMT divergence, okay.
SMT, Smart Money Technique, it's accumulating in here, whereas the NASDAQ is taking liquidity
out, so there's a cracking correlation between the two.
Usually they move in tandem, but at certain times, what times?
830, 930, at news events being released, okay, they'll create this divergence, and if you
have a bias, it's helpful, but if you don't know where it's going, you're going to many
times encounter what would look like SMT divergence, and then it disappears as they start moving
in concert with one another, so you have to be careful with that.
That's why I'm teaching, that's why I always teach, know what it's reaching for, okay,
the bias has been bullish, and for my framework, for my setup, because I gave you 4,000 and
I had very little time to work with anything this morning, I just hurried up and saw the
chart, I missed the actual ideal entry, I just used a close proximity entry with an
owner block, and there you go.
So if you look at the relationship of that fair value gap, dropping back down in higher
low than that of 830 versus the lower low made in NASDAQ, this is a stop out, this is
accumulation of longs, this is going to be the telltale sign that it's going to go higher.
If you look at what we did on 830, it already snapped down into this gap, and it's not likely
to go lower than that, there's no need to, okay, so it's being compressed, basically
like a spring, or more like a bomb really, I hate to say it so crude, but that's what
it is, it's like waiting, and then all of a sudden it explodes, it's waiting just below
that daily bearish order block, and it's digging up into that thing, that range on that up
close candle in the daily chart, so it's climbing up, up, up, up, and we watched to see if it
gets to the mean threshold, which is half of that bearish order block, or up close candle
in the daily chart, I was making reference to it at the beginning of the video.
Alright, so again we can see, zoomed in, price breaks back down into the fair value gap after
trading to the order block here, this is a 15 minute time frame order block by the way,
and then it rallies.
Inside this little area in here, there's one small little pull back into a fair value
one minute chart, I'll leave that for you to go into and study.
And here is the hourly chart, I want to kind of give you like a market structure perspective.
Here's where it's likely to be drawn to next, all of this movement down here, we completely
rebalanced all that, here is the fair value gap I had drawn on the lower time frame chart
just a moment ago before we moved back up to an hourly chart.
We have consolidated here ahead of running all the way up into this area here.
So notice what was happening, we had to low, retrace down into this low to high, discount,
fair value gap, rallies.
Dealing range low, dealing range high, retraces down into, discount, rallies.
Dealing range low, dealing range high, discount, fair value gap, order block, rally.
Consolidate, we rally, come back down into the smaller time frame, fair value gap, SMT
diversions, and rallies, and keeps pressing higher and higher and higher.
So my question to you is, how many of you first didn't listen to me when I said don't
trade?
Two, did you try to sell short, why?
The bias has been bullish, it's likely to do what, keep digging higher, we try not to
pick tops, and look what this has done, we've had a low, a lower low, a sudden dramatic
low that we came back up, had a shift in market structure here, then we retraced back down
into this imbalance, so we're seeing the market do what?
Keep going higher, keep going higher, picking up discount levels each time the algorithm
is picking up more accumulated longs to press deeper into all of this range and likely trade
into the buy side of the quarter here.
So you have to know what you're looking for, narrative and bias.
So what in this area, or over here, would constitute a short?
Because we have all this range in here that it's not likely to go up and go straight all
the way through all this stuff.
That's a high resistance liquidity run.
Not that it can't happen, but it's likely to not form or pan out.
Because we had so many supporting ideas in here, down close candles are supporting price,
it's just finding underlying order flow that is bullish.
So it's likely to go up just to keep going higher, not go up to go down.
Because to go up to go down, we have all of these ranges that we would have to pierce
and break through, and that requires a lot of, well, intent, not selling pressure, okay?
And the intent is to send this thing higher on the daily chart, which is why I took your
attention to that initial gap on the daily chart.
So if you found this one insightful, and hopefully you learned why today the range expansion
took place, why was it not a short, we've been bullish, we've been looking for price
to go higher.
And just for clarity, let me go back up, 4,000 was my objective, only because I mentioned
4,000 during the commentaries this week.
So when I was talking to you in lectures, I called this level.
So I wanted to give you a point of entry, and then target hitting it, and that was the
whole point of me showing you that little vignette on Twitter today, showing you that
a level I was looking for, how to frame a trade, how to set it up and engage it.
Because it was setting up this trade here, take this for your notes, because it gave
a nice run here earlier, before 7 o'clock in the morning.
That means we're probably going to have a deep retracement and look for an ideal scenario
like we outlined with the SMT divergence.
So SMT usually will occur around a 930 time period when there has already been a nice
early run before 7 o'clock or at 7 o'clock.
So we got real close to 7 o'clock here, but I'm not limited to this model.
I know some of you were questioning with pointed remarks on Twitter, what are we doing here?
Why are we not using the time frame that's used for the model?
I'm showing you, again, just proof that these things deliver as I teach them.
Now, I have not only taught what I've revealed on YouTube, I have lots of students.
I have students in my paid group, I have casual people that come through and watch one video
or two videos, and I want them to see things that's being taught from my library of concepts.
So if I can see this set up early in the day, before the 7 o'clock in the morning, to me
it gives me insight.
It gives me an expectation around what the 930 opening is going to be like.
So if I get an early run like this, my first thought is I need to go to SMT later on at
930 because it's probably going to require some kind of a cracking correlation to set
up the next lake if it's going to have one.
It's Thursday, tomorrow's Friday we're going to go into a holiday weekend.
I will not be trading tomorrow, I will not be trading on Monday.
I'm going to be doing one video for my private group tomorrow and it's probably going to
be an early video, not so much a commentary for price action because it's a weekend and
Memorial Day is on Monday, so volume is probably going to be light on Friday.
So if you're going to be trading, you study in the morning session, lead the afternoon
to the gamblers, volume just probably won't be on your side in the afternoon, everybody
is probably going to be going away for a long weekend and don't trade on Monday.
Take the day off, enjoy it, have hot dogs, hamburgers, relax, do what you got to do to
be a family person.
I'm going to be doing the same and until I talk to you Lord willing next Tuesday, enjoy
weekend and your holiday, be safe.